what do you think is the meaning of life
on earth
what is the meaning of our human
intelligent life
well i think it's very clear that um
we have an evolutionary story
that um
is only getting
challenged around the edges you know we
we have a very clear understanding of
the evolution of life
and um the meaning is you know we are
here
as a consequence of um
materialistic processes
uh that
you know began uh in our sense
you know with the
establishment of the earth the four and
a half billion years ago whatever it was
and then water and
oxygen and and so on um
and uh you know we are the astonishing
uh
uh consequence
of um
the evolution of of cells and and
multicellular organisms
uh
the word random
is the wrong word to use unless you
understand what it means
you know
it didn't happen by chance but a lot of
random events had to happen to make this
possible
and those random events of course
are the production of uh appropriate
mutations
but the um you know the meaning of life
is
there is no meaning
it's it the you know the really big
mystery of life is why is there a
universe
and that same y propagates itself
through the whole of it
through the whole process of it for the
emergence of planets the virgins first
of all galaxies of
uh star systems of planets of
the proteins required to construct the
single cell organisms and the single
cell organism becoming complex organisms
and
some of the clever fish
crawling out onto the land and
and the whole of it and then there's
fire some some clever
uh clever guy or lady invented fire and
then now here we are
uh it just does seem
speaking as a human kind of special that
we're able to reflect on the whole thing
where the whole wonderful story is so
much more interesting than the stories
produced by religion yeah it is it is
beautiful but it just seems special that
us humans are able to
control including construct write
religions and
construct stories yeah and and also do
science
that seems
that seems kind of amazing it seems like
the universe
is such
that it it um it creates
beings like us that are able to
investigate
it
and that and that that's why there's
this longing for why
it's just uh
such a beautiful little pocket of
complexity created by the universe it
seems like um
it seems like there should be a y but
maybe there's just an infinite number of
universes and this is the one
that uh
led to this particular set of humans
even without an infinite number of
universes i bet there's an infinite
number of intelligent beings throughout
this universe yeah now that we know how
many planets are
have the right sort of conditions
you know which is what i can't remember
a lot you know it's some significant
percentage of all planets
um
then
then there are apparently billions of
planets
and
there's every i mean things happen so
quickly on earth you know once you've
got water then uh you've got life and um
it did not take long for for life to
evolve in in the big scheme of things
and if you think you look out there
say there's a nearly infinite number of
intelligent civilizations
one dimension you could look at is the
proclivity to violence they have it's
interesting to think
what level of violence is useful
for um
extending the life of a civilization so
we have a particular set of violence in
our history
maybe being too peaceful is a problem in
the early days
uh maybe being too violent quite
obviously is as a problem so you look at
viruses what kind of viruses on earth
propagate and succeed if you're too
deadly that's a big problem
uh if you're not deadly enough that's
also a problem so
so that is a fascinating exploration of
i don't see any evidence i don't see
where you're coming from when you say
that being too peaceful is a problem
well because so i'll say it this way
death
is a way
to get rid of suboptimal solutions
so violence but there's lots of ways to
die without violence right
to me death in itself is violence and
you you can i mean a lot of people that
talk about for example longevity and
and disease and all that kind of stuff
they see death is a
this is the way they they talk about it
and it's interesting to philosophically
think of it that way
death is
it's like mass murder that's happening
it's like people that try to from a
biological perspective help extend life
they see that you're
you're helping
the most
the biggest atrocity in the history of
human civilization from their
perspective
is
not
allocating all our resources to solving
death
right because death is a kind of
violence it is the kind of murder that
we're allowing uh to be committed on us
by nature and so
so the flip side of that is death makes
way for new life
for new ideas
and so that is but but that's got
nothing to do with with peace versus war
you know i mean you you have animals
that are very very peaceful but but they
evolved just in the same way as other
animals do they just don't do it with
with death caused by violence and
violent death is premature death surely
i mean you know i don't mind about
people dying
um you know what i mind about is people
dying uh in the
in in their youth
prematurely but some people would say
all death is premature it certainly
feels that way it's uh
died too soon anyone who's ever died
died too soon yeah well i mean if if we
can become like sequoias you know and
and live for
hundreds of years and thousands of years
that would be great
do you ponder your own mortality are you
afraid of death
i don't think i'm afraid of it
you know i'm reconciled to the fact it's
going to happen
i just feel frustrated because i enjoy
life you know and i don't want to
to leave the party
yeah
it's kind of a fun party
i don't want to leave the party either
so however we got here we made one heck
of an awesome party and you're right
uh having a party with a little bit less
violence in it is an even more fun party
richard i'm deeply honored that you
spent time with me today your work is
amazing it's inc includes
some of the deepest thinking about
our human history and the nature of
human civilization so again thank you so
much for talking today it's an honor oh
thanks for a great questions it's a
really fun conversation
you